[Music]
with the introduction of its new Yaris
Toyota recently decided to stop offering
its diesel-powered version in Germany
taking its place is hybrid gasoline and
electric drive Toyota's had these
combined drive trains and volume
production since 1997 one of the few sub
compacts with hybrid drive the Yaris
starts off with hardly a sound car mr.
Ronnie lipstick doesn't see hybrid
drivers just a gimmick but as truly the
best choice with the Yaris the gasoline
powered versions consume a lot more fuel
to go energy efficiency is the small
hybrids main selling point most of the
technology has been taken from the
second generation Prius in the new
European driving cycle the full hybrid
consumes just 3.3 liters of fuel its
emissions of 75 grams of co2 per
kilometer are impressively low Romi
discovers that with some concentration
he can keep the fuel consumption around
3.3 litres even without concentrating
consumption stays under 5 liters for
city driving but that comes at the
expense of road performance it takes a
while for the engine to heave the R is
up to its top speed Toyota provides its
hybrid drive buyers some help we're
driving optimally and infographic and
the infotainment display tracks the flow
of energy recuperative braking helps to
keep the battery charged as long as the
braking isn't too sudden and a light
touch is needed on the accelerator to
stay well inside the green eco area
he made brownie notes that the standard
automatic transmission may unnerve
drivers was sensitive hearing whenever
he accelerates he hears a monotone
background noise
but if you flow with city traffic at a
moderate speed the continuously variable
transmission and the hybrid technology
tend to make life easier
relaxation rather than driving fun is
the idea behind the hybrid compact and
it deserves mention that the engineers
have toned down the background noise
compared to previous models through
small improvements to the drivetrain and
engine mounts alongside the exterior
badges blue edge to Toyota logos refer
to the environmentally-friendly drive
technology the interior offers little to
complain about the controls for the
sat-nav may be narrow but they're
clearly marked a tachometer is nowhere
to be found
since the batteries mounted under the
rear seat
the cargo space is the same as in the
non hybrid yarnís rani likes the fuel
efficiency and long-lasting quality if
you meet an undemanding car for the city
stop and go traffic this little Japanese
hybrid might not be a bad choice kia is
expanding its family of SUVs having to
the Sorento and the Sportage the smaller
kia stomach based on the REO will round
out the smaller end of Korean carmakers
SUVs range
there's a choice of three
gasoline-powered engines and one diesel
all with front-wheel drive and ranging
from 62 to 88 kilowatts prices start
from fifteen thousand seven hundred
ninety euros
Daimler Trucks is celebrating the launch
of its new fuse OE Kanter in New York
it's the world's first all-electric
light truck in volume production
deliveries to car buyers in the US
Europe and Japan will happen this year
the e Kanter should help reduce noise
levels in big cities large-scale
production is planned to start in 2019
[Music]